after loaning spider-man out to the
Avengers at Marvel Studios Sony is eager
to get its own adjacent marvel universe
back on track with the other characters
in its stable and some Hardy is hoping
to start things off right with venom
making a spider-man movie that doesn't
really focus on the wall crawler is a
tall order but it looks like Sony's
found the right man for the job
he is white Tom Hardy will blow everyone
away as venom when the movie hits II it
says in October 2018 familiar territory
party doesn't just bring name
recognition to venom he also brings the
chops when the stars finally aligned for
director George Miller to get Mad Max
fury road off the ground he tapped hardy
to follow Mel Gibson and bringing max to
life it was a tall order but Hardy did a
perfect job of capturing the quiet
action-packed intensity that made max
such a fan favorite character the movie
also featured some of the most
ridiculously insane stunts ever
attempted so whatever Sony could sub for
venom Hardy should be prepared plus when
you think of Hardy's resume his role as
Bane in Christopher Nolan's The Dark
Knight Rises is likely one of the first
to come to mind Hardy joined the final
installment in Nolan's Batman trilogy to
play the classic DC bad a one of his
most physical and menacing roles in
comic movie history a character who
pushed the Dark Knight further than he's
ever been pushed and almost beat him in
the end
you don't fear - you welcome it your
punishment must be master beer we don't
know exactly which direction they'll be
taking this new version of venom but it
stands to reason he'll be somewhere
between villain and antihero so Hardy's
experience as a straight-up comics body
should come in handy much needed range
funds had mixed reactions to the first
venom teaser mostly because it didn't
really show off all that much venom
instead the film is being framed as a
psychological thriller dealing with the
fallout of mind-melding with a symbiote
it's an aspect of the story that
certainly been explored in the comics
but rarely on the big screen with any
real depth outside of his two biggest
sharma roles party has a varied career
that should serve him well with whatever
curveballs playing the character might
call for parties had roles in everything
from Sucker Punch to Inception and took
on period parts and films like the
revenant he's even gone the romantic
comedy roots in this Means War
more recently he's been spreading his
wings on the small screen in critical
hits like peaky blinders and he reunited
with Christopher Nolan for the acclaimed
writer directors hit World War two drama
Dunkirk clearly Hardy's ready for pretty
much anything spot-on luck
the first venom teaser trailer gave us a
look at Hardy's version of Eddie Brock
and at least from an aesthetic
standpoint he seems to have nailed a
party's rough-and-tumble vibe and
muscular frame are a perfect match for
the comics take on the character anytime
an actor signs on for a superhero movie
it's typically assumed they'll spend a
decent bit of time behind a mask party
pretty much never got out from behind
his pain mask in the Dark Knight Rises
but that doesn't look to be a concern in
venom or the teaser footage showed Hardy
playing Brock outside the venom suit and
they will certainly see the suit in the
full film it looks like Hardy will have
ample opportunity to shine as the Prok
we know from the comics when he isn't
behind that toothy symbiote face also
working in Hardy's favor
the only other live-action version of
Eddie Brock we've ever seen came
courtesy of That 70's Show vets
Topher Grace and spider-man 3 nothing
against grace but it'd be difficult for
Hardy not to be an improvement
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff and know
your love to
[Music]